T'es sérieux là ? Demain j'ai un rendez-vous important à sept heures,
faut absolument que je dorme !
Eh ben, tu ne rentres pas !
Je te déteste...
T'es vraiment la personne la plus nulle du monde !
J'espère bien !
Pourquoi j'arrive pas à dormir ?
BOUM (x2)
Plus tu t'énerves, moins tu pourras rentrer
TOC (x3)
Pourquoi tu me réveilles ?
Ben... J'essaye de dormir là...
Bah dors alors...
Attends, attends
Quoi encore ?
Tu veux pas me tenir un peu compagnie ?
Peut-être que ça m'aiderait à m'endormir...
Elle a fermé...
- Je te l'avais bien dit. Enfin, je dis ça, je dis rien.
*Bruit étrange*
*Ronflement*
- Bah quoi ? C'est pas ma faute !
Hein ? J'entends pas j'ai des boules Quies
Et puis j'en ai rien à foutre
- Tricheur !
*Alarme*
- Eh, oh ! Faut aller travailler là mon petit !
Oh non s'il te plaît, laisse-moi juste 5 minutes
Encore 5 minutes, promis
- Mouais, on les connaît tes 5 minutes...
- Heureusement que t'as appuyé sur la touche "snooze"
Oh, oh je me rendors
- NON !
Elle est ouverte là ?
- Là tu rentres direct parce que t'es complètement bourré,
mais demain matin tu feras moins le malin.
Eh, ferme ta gueule
- Mais qu'est-ce qu'il a ? Il a prit de la drogue ?
Juste en bas là, nickel, parfait
- C'est quoi ce bruit?
- On est dimanche t'as pas mis de réveil ?
-Bah, non.
*Bruit de perceuse*   -T'as fini avec ta perceuse connard ?!
-C'est bon t'as fait assez de trous là!
-Bon bah... C'est le week-end
Tu peux me faire faire une énorme insomnie, c'est pas grave, demain j'ai rien, je peux dormir toute la journée.
- Vas-y, entres !
- Espèce de batard !
*rire*
- Ok, demain j'ai un rendez-vous hyper important pour moi
- Là, laisses-moi rentrer au moins quelques heures s'teuplaît.
Ça fait trois heures j'suis devant, j'en peux plus, j'suis épuisé bordel !
- J'ai dis non !
- Putain !
- Ok, faut que j'arrête de penser à tout ça !
Faut que je pense à rien !
Mais quand je pense à rien, je pense quand même au fait de ne pas penser, c'est un cercle vicieux.
- Oui ! Essaye tes petites techniques.. Tu as raison !
-Toi, essayes pas de m'énerver... Faut pas que je m'énerve.
-Oh pardon. *rire*
- J'ai une idée !
- *rires forts*
- Mon nez.. il est où mon nez ?
- Norman !
- *ensemble* ouais !
- Qu'est-ce que tu fais là ?
Arrête !
Norman !
Tu arrêtes ça !
*On va refaire la fusée ! Au même endroit que la limace !*
-Tu me regardes ?!
Tu me réponds !
Tu te souviens ? À l'école... Tes petits camarades, parce que t'avais les cheveux frisés, ils t'appelaient 'le mouton'.
Behh behh Sale mouton! Ils disaient
(Sale mouton Norman... Sale mouton Norman !)
Tu te souviens ?!
- Tu me laches pas papa ! Non ,Non ,Non j'te laches pas
(Ouais.. Wahhhhh)
Arrête !
Arrête... Arrêêête !
*musique*
*musique plus forte*
Fin